austin peterson écrivain activiste
politique c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur
[Musique]
austin peterson merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france alors tout d'abord ce
constat le corona virus a tué plus
d'américains que la guerre du vietnam
une guerre on le sait qui demeure l'un
des plus grands traumatismes vécus par
les américains au 20e siècle
du coup est ce que cela change la
perception des américains vis-à-vis du
virus h5 soirée funk jazz
je pense que le choc initial du au début
de l'épidémie est passé
pour beaucoup d'américains mais
lorsqu'on regarde le nombre des morts
aux etats-unis il faut mettre de côté
new york que l'état du new york tu
restes des états unis l'immense majorité
des morts liés aux coronavirus aux états
unis étaient dos à new york et le reste
se répartissant sur le reste du
territoire
effectivement c'est une tragédie chaque
mort est une perte tragique mais les
américains ont une perception différence
du taux de mortalité
je te tue ton commence à montrer que le
taux de contamination dans certaines
communautés américaines est bien plus
élevé que l'a montré que l'ont montré
les tests
cela pourrait signifier en théorie que
le taux de mortalité ducobu 19 serait
donc inférieur en fait à 1% bien moins
que les premières estimations de 2 à 3%
on nous avait annoncé deux millions de
morts
et maintenant
n'arrive 650 morts 650 1000 meurent donc
je pense que la perspective s'élargit
alors on va y revenir au nombre de
quatre contaminé mais avant dans ce
contexte on vient d'apprendre qu'un
essai américain avait montré qu'un
traitement à base de raismes désire
accélérer de 31% le temps de
rétablissement des malades du colis 19
comment cette nouvelle est perçu dans le
pays à ce qu'elle fait débat comme la
chloroquine l'a fait en france par
exemple
à damas doa sachez que c'est une
excellente question
je viens d'évoquer le sujet ce matin
avec le sénateur de l'état du missouri
nous avons évoqué ce médicament ainsi
que les 36 chloroquine je suis beaucoup
de patients effectivement eu de
meilleurs résultats après le contact
avec ces deux médicaments mais les
essais cliniques sont encore rares et
parmi ceux qui ont dû alors les
résultats sont assez décevants donc nous
allons devoir attendre afin de savoir si
des essais plus poussées montreront bien
que ce désir ce médicament anti viral ou
si la chloroquine remplissent vraiment
la promesse je peux vous dire qu'une
personne qui a attrapé le co fait 19 a
été très à traiter avec les roxy
chloroquine il faudra encore un peu de
temps afin de pouvoir mener de
véritables tests
bien sûr la question finale sera est-ce
qu'un vaccin sera développé et est ce
qu'il sera efficace car beaucoup de
personnes savent que nous avons un
vaccin contre la grippe mais la grippe
existe encore vaccin contre la grippe
il est efficace qu environ 30%
seul moyen de se tirer de cette crise
est le plus difficile c'est à dire qu'il
faudrait savoir si nous pouvons nous se
mettra à l'immunité collective
alors pour revenir au nombre de cas de
contamination à les états unis ont
franchi la barre symbolique d'un million
de cas de coronavirus diagnostiquée
alors il se dit que ce grand nombre est
lié notamment au fait qu'il ya eu
énormément de dépistage un dépistage
massif est ce que c'est vraiment le cas
politique de tests très rapidement et
les deux minutes est ce plus qu'aucune
autre monde
le nombre de tests positifs c'est
environ 10 % des personnes testées
cela ne représentait 4 6% des personnes
à l'échelle nationale avoir des
estimations fiables des personnes qui
sont contaminées nécessiteront des tests
aléatoires et pourtant cela sera le seul
moyen de vraiment savoir combien
d'américains ont été contaminées donc
j'en reviens à ce que j'évoquais avec
les tests aux anticorps en ce moment
nous testions à les opposer aux états
unis les auditions montrent que par
exemple en californie du sud
[Musique]
3000 à test positif des souris s'est
montré plutôt timide voire trois cent
mille personnes potentiellement
infectées
ils étaient arbitraires sont la seule
manière de savoir combien de personnes
ont été contaminées
mais d'après nos informations il serait
relativement possible pour que deux
personnes le court la grèce que nous ne
le pensons et non simplement pas montré
de symptômes ou ne se sont pas fait
tester cela serait une bonne chose si
plus de personnes ont une somme très de
symptômes cela signifie que le taux de
mortalité est en fait en dessous de 1%
donc le taux de mortalité du coc u19
pourrait bien être comparable à celui de
la grippe saisonnière
un médecin me l'a dit ce matin et
beaucoup d'autres epidémiologiste comme
dr castot sont de la même opinion le coc
u19 ne serait pas plus dangereux que la
pipe
merci beaucoup austin peterson d'avoir
partagé votre regard sur la situation
aux états unis je rappelle que vous êtes
écrivain et activiste politique
merci pour que